for 80 days and nights they have held
out against the russians
the defenders of azov style preventing
the invaders from taking complete
control of mariupol
but now say their wives and mothers it
is almost over
i think that this is the end
natalia married her husband who's in
azov style in april apart but online as
the siege went on
his last photo
here his face is yellow completely
he has lost
much weight
more than 20 kilos and when you last
spoke to him what did he say to you
he told us that
the ring
around the circle around the other steel
is getting thinner
and
the end will be soon
do you think you'll see him again
yes i hope
in my mind i think uh that
there is no chances but
in my heart
i feel
that we can save them
julia showed me a photo of her husband
alexander and their three-year-old son
she is desperate to be reunited with him
um
they're begging the outside world to
negotiate with russia and extract the
fighters svetlana's son is among them
against the odds she told me she
believes she will
a ukrainian commander urged america to
intervene and get his fighters out
of
but russia has turned down offers by
turkey to have the garrison extracted
and today russia's foreign minister was
upping the ante again talking of a
far-reaching war with the west
the choice we're making now it has
already been made and it is that the
collective west has announced a total
hybrid war on us
it's difficult to forecast how long all
of this will last but it's clear that
the consequences will be felt by
everybody without exception
we've done everything to avoid a direct
clash but the challenge has been thrown
to us and we will accept it
on the ground in ukraine russia's forces
are retreating after weeks of fierce
fighting around hakeev pulling back
leaving the hulks of abandoned armor the
russians made talk of a war lasting
indefinitely but for now at least it is
still going against them
dominic waghorn sky news keeve